all right thank you for attending my
talk um well just as I plugged in my
laptop I noticed that somehow the
Commerce on the Beamer got changed I'm
not really sure what happened but I'm
just gonna wing it and if there is
anything weird happening I'll be sure to
talk you through it I'm painting a word
picture yeah so I'm Nelson I'm one of
the organizers of Pi data Amsterdam my
educational background is in cognitive
neuroscience and then I started working
as a software developer using different
languages so have some experience with
C++ and Java but biten still has a
special place in my heart and this
project is something that I did as part
of my master's thesis and yeah this is
something that I really want to tell you
more about yeah so as the title says we
used overhead video to capture to
analyze grouping behavior of dancers in
a silent disco I'm just gonna start with
a bit of background and yeah this color
change is really weird but we'll just go
through it okay so yeah music movements
and social behavior there are they're
all linked so it's very natural for
people to just move in synchrony with
each other so when two people are
dancing it's very natural just to move
to the same beat and it's also very
natural for people to move to music this
already starts at an early age and well
research has shown that it fosters group
cohesion and social bombing so if you're
dancing together you're more likely to
see the other person as part of your
group when you're not dancing in
synchrony you're more likely to see the
other person as part of not your group
or not part of your group and yeah as I
say this is a natural behavior even
children showed his behavior already and
it's also been shown to increase
cooperative behavior in children so this
is why investigating music in relation
to social behavior but also like music
to personal behavior is a very
interesting topic in yeah Reese
the field of music cognition but now we
have a technical challenge and so I'm
gonna talk a bit about a technical
background first because how is this
research generally conducted here on the
slide you see a picture of yeah of the
ritmo lab at Oslo University which is a
motion tracking laboratory that they use
for investigating how people move to
music and generally these lamps are very
small they're limited to a small sample
size because like looking at this room
you can only fit around maybe two or
three people in there there are some
bigger lamps that maybe fit five or six
and it also presents an unnatural
setting because you need a lot of lights
and for these labs to work because
people often have a funny suit with a
lot of balls on them to really to be
able to be tracked by the cameras so
yeah that's not a very natural
environment to dance on because first
you come into the laboratory a
researcher tells you all about the
procedure and then you're in a brightly
lit room maybe with some other people
and then you're just gonna have to dance
to it and yeah even standing here on
stage I would kind of not really start
dancing so I I bet you can imagine how
it would feel like in a motion tracking
lab and also these rooms are expensive
to maintain because there's a lot of
technology used it all has to be kept in
working order calibrated yeah it's just
very expensive so part of this research
was also to see can we have can we find
or can we have this as a flexible and
somewhat cheaper alternative so that's
where silent disco is come in so I do
want to ask all of you like who has
participated in silent disco so far ok
so I see well a little under half maybe
one third of people then so in a silent
disco everyone gets a pair of headphones
and on this picture
for instance this guy on the correct
color picture he has green lights
showing on his headphone and then the
people under a bit mayor bit more to
back they're supposed to have blue
lights and the lights indicate what
channel you listen to so you have
multiple channels that you can switch
between or not and so if someone is
listening to this guy is listening to
the green Channel
apparently so huh it looks like he's
having the time of his life and other
people around him know that he's
listening to a specific Channel the
people in the blue Channel they listen
to different music so that's where the
in-group out-group part comes in because
if you're both listening to the green
Channel you know it's and you dance in
synchrony you might feel more connected
to those people then when I'm listening
to something green and you're listening
to something on the blue channel then we
might feel part of different groups so
it also presents a kind of social
coordination behavior and I've got some
video to show just to give a short idea
of what is heard in discos so here they
layered some music over it and it's just
people dancing and where did my audio go
okay there's supposed to be audio with
this but apparently it's not coming
through so just people dancing and one
of the ideas of silent disco for
instance in the Netherlands we have this
festival called blow lands and on the
first night they don't they don't have a
sound permission from the local
government yet so they can't play music
Trudy's loudspeakers so what they do is
they organise a really big sounding
disco because well Simon discuss our
silence that's where the next video was
supposed to come in with audio because
this is this ask the question like what
does client quite clubbing sounds like
and if this all works then well ok
apparently it doesn't but it's very
natural for people to sing along with
music or yell
there are excitement and well you can do
it suddenly so pretty much anywhere and
the point of this slide was basically to
show you that silent discos aren't
actually silent and often you can hear
people singing out of tune because well
they can't really listen what they can't
really hear themselves singing so yeah
this is a very good slide to play
without audio so let's just go through
to the objective so I'm just going to
talk you briefly through the research
project from start to finish and so the
research question is how two dancers
group depending on the music they listen
to so we have two different playlists
and we want to investigate our grouping
behavior in a silent disco settings with
the multi-channel headphones as I
explained just now and you can do two
things in a silent disco either you can
make curated playlists so I make
playlist 1 and playlist to tie them to a
channel and I have just predefined what
music each channel is listening to
another option is for instance you can
have multiple DJs trying to battle
against each other maybe do as kind of
popularity thing where people can switch
from one to the other there's a lot of
different options which also makes it
interesting to research and then the
technical question is can we use
overhead video to answer such questions
so what we did we organized a overhead
video um we organized a silent disco had
a camera suspended at an angle above the
dance floor and I'll just record the
video while people are having a good
time they're dancing they're getting
some drinks at the bar dancing with
friends and just that's pretty much
having a normal night out so then well
we have the images we need to analyze
them and the way we investigated the
grouping behavior is to graph on link so
we created undirected graphs I'm gonna
go more into detail about this later so
that's roughly an idea from start to
finish what I'm going through but first
I want to do a step back
namely the technical problem statement
and it starts with acquiring the data
because well I live in Amsterdam the
silent discos were
organised in the UK and they have well a
bunch of big video files of like 220
gigabytes in one file sitting in the UK
and needing to get to Amsterdam it's
quite difficult to do that via I don't
know any cloud provider we tried we
tried Google Drive that's failed
miserably so in the end we just ended up
shipping a hard drive to Amsterdam and a
really fun thing about shipping hard
drives around is that I wanted to bring
this hard drive so I could show you some
of the video and some of the data but
it's a hard drive and that's sitting at
my desk in Amsterdam because frankly I
forgot it so I asked my partner to make
a picture of it and so I could at least
included that's why I also also showed
the videos a little earlier to give you
an idea of what the Simon disco Luke's
and well sadly not sounds like okay so
that's challenge one it was solved took
a few weeks but we got the data and then
I could start playing with it one of the
first thing you notice is that it's a
yeah it's a dark environment and um on
this slide well you can't really see the
signal because there's a lot of noise
coming from these environment these
pieces in the environment it was
recorded at a museum where they had
exhibition pieces still being lit up so
this is a lot of noise and you should be
able to see some specs alternate phone
lights as a signal I'm sorry the
environment lines another challenge with
this kind of data is that you have a
varying number of participants like
people are having a regular night out
they go to the bar get some drinks they
walk onto the dance floor and off the
dance floor and also because the camera
is suspended at an angle people obscure
each other so if I have two lights on my
headphones and I turn around and the
camera is over there then well at some
point you can only see one light you can
only see two lights
if someone very tall is standing in
front of me well I'm not really visible
anymore that's something we didn't
really take care of because we first
wanted to just prove that this kind of
technique works as I said two lights per
headphones
difficulty with turning
so we have two data sets that I want to
mention the first one is that I the
first one is what I built my pipeline
around just to get started with and was
recorded in Manchester we presented
people with two channels with curated
playlists and they couldn't switch
between the different playlists so what
we did is we semi randomly distributed
their headphones to have an
approximately similar number of red and
green channels and the playlist that we
presented were ear worms and a match
control and so in musical terms an ear
worm is a catchy song or a catchy tune
that is known to run continually through
people's heads
these were sourced from literature and
then we match them with songs that were
not known as an ear worm so we match
them on musical features like tempo
Tambor pitch etc and also these were all
pop songs of popular music
and well here we have another screenshot
from that same data set then the second
dataset is some is one that we so in
this in the setup of designing disco we
did some improvements we made it a bit
darker to have less noise around it and
that's also the data set that I used to
validate the code that I've written for
the first one it was also recorded in
Manchester at the same venue I actually
and this time we had three channels and
this time people were also able to
switch and let's see we see some like
pink here some greenish here but
basically the channels they had were red
green and blue and well so just imagine
that you see some red and green and blue
dots here please and the playlist that
we presented was pop music spanning
different eras so basically from the 40s
to 60s then from the 70s to the 90s and
then 90s to base or basically post to
thousands
so really modern music so at first I'm
going through the workflow well first I
had to define a sampling right because
we have around two and half hours of
video per dataset also a file of 222
gigabytes so what I did was I just
select one in every ten frames it was
recorded at 25 frames per minute so that
still leaves XI or 25 frames per second
I'm sorry so that still leaves you with
2 and all frames per second of data that
to deal with but it also really speeds
up the processing time and then first
and then 4 so since we have red green
and blue as primary colors that we use
sorry so what I did was I the video was
recorded in RGB and we have red and
green and in the other case blue as
colors that we were interested in I just
simply split it per color layer and so
we have so we have some red in where we
have the red and green color layers and
then we did at edge detection on it so
just use a very simple model to detect
the edges and you'll see that well of
course we have to know the the
environmental pieces presenting a noise
but then you also see the headphone
lights being clearly picked up in both
frames so yeah noise that's a big part
of a big big issue so we have these
environmental lights that we don't want
to get picked up so at first I started
just drawing a simple mask and this was
very rudimentary just hand-drawn I
didn't really achieve what I wanted so
then I went through an iterative process
where I selected two frame drew the
contours and then just masked out every
contour that wasn't part of the actual
data and then you can come up with a
mask like this where all the
environmental pieces are blacked out
while you leave as much of the dance
floor available as possible and then
superimposed
over the dance floor you got it can kind
of get an idea of how much data you
still have left and then again go back
to the different color layers we do some
we do the a tree section and then we
model the contours so here you can more
clearly see that we have some red this
because of the color inverse conversion
it's pinkish and there we have some
people listening to the green channel
over there and then using the weighted
center we defined like the midpoints the
weighted center of each of the different
headphone lights that got picked up and
x and y coordinates of those data points
we used as input for the graph modelling
so then for every frame we created an
undirected graph so here we see that our
points are connected based on distance
so we set this an upper limit as a
decent threshold so if so if someone is
roughly within 1/2 meters of you then we
would say they are connected as being
part of the same group this doesn't take
into account whether people are facing
each other or not so that's one
potential improvement and then based on
these graphs that we created for each
frames we took the clock we define
clustering measures namely the local
local clustering so that's a measure to
see how connected my neighbors are
compared to each other global clustering
which defines how many connect to try
how many triangles there are compared to
connected triplets and also the vertex
degree which is simply the number of
connections that each vertex has so now
I'm going to go to the results and I
really hope these graphs will shell
correctly with a color change okay so
for the first data set with only two
with only two color channels we have
from the top to bottom first the number
of participants that we pick up what we
can very clearly see is that we picked
up more red than green participants this
is something that we did control for in
defining the clustering measures so we
did control we did normalize the number
of vertices that we picked up and what
we can clearly see especially in the
local clustering not as much in a global
clustering and we can again clearly see
it in a vertex degree that red is more
connected than green the way the reason
that global clustering is a lot more
noisy is that it lends a different
weight to I have to say this correctly
yeah local clustering it gives a
different way to sparsely connected
vertices so that's why this is probably
this is a bit more noisy and the
interesting thing is that the red
channel which I didn't which I forgot to
mention earlier is that the red channel
is the air worms that people were
listening to and one of the hypotheses
on that dataset was that ear worms being
songs that run through people's heads
are more memorable and therefore it's
more likely for people to feel more
connected to each other so that's the
takeaway from the first dataset and then
the second data set we use mostly as a
way of verifying that the code I wrote
worked for a different data so basically
this is the training and then the next
one is their test set and what we see
here is that first of all there's
something weird happening at the end
where suddenly there is a spike in the
number of vertices that gets picked up
that's probably because the dancefloor
was emptying out and some weird noisy
noise issues happen this is supposed to
be blue 9 by the way and here we see
that because people could change in the
colors that there is some inversion
happening between red and green and so
when Rhett goes up Green goes slightly
down it's not a one on one relation
also not to be expected and again we see
that local clustering has higher
signal-to-noise ratio than global
clustering and then vertex degree I
assume because the spike here is doing
something weird it's messing up the
scale of it but the takeaway is that yes
with a different data set we can use the
same code base to give some reliable
answers let's see how much time do you
guys still have all right
so then at this point the part of the
project was formally finished but then
it's one of these projects that I would
love to keep working on if I provided I
have enough time so for instance there
are some future directions that I want
to mention and one of the first things
that I wanted to do was just improve the
code just define an API or GUI for ease
of use so that other researchers would
also be able to use this code and this
would also come with some pipeline
improvements for instance the data
transfer so that we're not reliant on
shipping hard drives around and now I'm
not really sure how how I would solve
this but that's just one point so either
get the code to the researchers or make
sure that the data can be shipped to the
code easier more easily
well detection of noise features this
was a manual process I all the masking
was done manually so that's something I
would like to automate I will try to get
a better sampling rate because one in
every 10 frames is also relatively noisy
you could do something with I don't know
spreading out frames or just combining
multiple frames to get a better
signal-to-noise ratio for instance
smoothing between frames also assess the
stability of signals so these
environmental pieces were very
stationary between frames so if it's if
something is not moving then it's
probably a noise feature because people
are moving around and dancing and one
thing that we didn't do yet because we
only looked at motion in the room
is to integrate it with the music that
was played so for each video we have
accompanying playlists so we know at
which point a new song starts or at
which point a new section starts and
that would be very interesting to look
at to see whether people's behavior
changes at different piece parts of the
playlist or different parts of the songs
you can also integrate it with for
instance an analysis of musical features
now that's what I want you to keep it up
and well thank you for attending my talk
[Applause]
[Music]
ok
then questions all right thank you
so I heard you wanted to limit yourself
to make an easy setup and my question is
if you had the bird's eye perspective
would that still be easier is it like
orally too much and even thinking of not
one camera but if the room is too big
for a bird's eye perspective to have
like multiple cameras and cascading them
to kind of one input what do you think
about that or did you consider that
specifically with Berta Burt sighs miss
Jeff perspective you mean from the
ceiling some just having like a 210
Amanda that was something that was
considered but it wasn't practical in
the space but yes and also that was out
of my control so the data set was
already present before I started working
on the project but that's something
definitely that you can take into
account for a future sign of discos
there might be the problem though that
that the lights are on the sides of the
headphones so if you have something
suspended directly above them those
might not be picked up as well but you
could definitely do something with
superimposing multiple viewpoints and
you get a more reliable signal thank you
I wanted to ask a bit about noise
removal so you explained how you mask by
hand and in the second dataset what did
this mask still work or you had to do
something else so for the second dataset
I had to create a specific a new mask
also using the same process so taking a
frame masking the noise features and
then try repeating that process until I
was satisfied with the amount of signal
choice that was present so that's
something that you need to customize for
every dataset at this point
hey great talk thank you I was wondering
with the day that you do you have can
you track clusters in terms of because
if if I think of a night out you usually
have a group of people who stay roughly
in the same location and then one person
goes away get some drinks something like
that so can you kind of capture that in
terms of follow these groups and if they
grow or shrink and these types of things
yeah that should definitely be possible
because well people are moving around in
well not really predictable patterns but
between different frames the patterns
are very relatively similar so yes I
would expect that you could be able to
do that thank you
any more questions so maybe I would say
in max planck with zebra finch actually
they are checking for the collective
behavior and they also have the problems
that they contract directly all the
birds since like some of them are hiding
or some of them are getting closer but
for now they are trained barcode
tracking and also plus GPS tracking I
don't know if it will be possible then
you would have more accurate data then
you wouldn't have this noise problem so
I'm also looking for this technology
that I'm working with pigeons so to try
to track them individual tracking is
easy but when I have like more than ten
pigeons that like and checking for their
collective behavior I'm also looking for
other solutions like maybe a barcode or
maybe GPS
trekking just kind of a suggestion or
listen interesting should suggestion I
think we should talk more about the face
to face thank you
okay one more question no no no okay
then thank you very much Nelson and
another round of applause please